et pour en débattre pierre litlle un
porte parole du mouvement libre bonsoir
pierre lys ya à vos côtés frédéric
france elle membre du collectif 19
collectif citoyen du 19e arrondissement
frédérique france l on avait eu le
plaisir de vous il ya quelques semaines
c'était à l'époque où les habitants
commençaient à attirer des tirs de
mortiers un pas vous mais bon certains
tellement qu'il n'en pouvait plus depuis
un les migrants apparemment par les
migrants pardonnez moi excusez moi aucun
lien les consommateurs de crack ont été
regroupés dans le parc la nuit est ce
que ça améliorer les choses oui ou non
je les ai peut-être qu'on n'a pas vu
qu'il habitait pas qu'on puisse dire que
ça et améliorer les choses je pense
surtout que ça déplacé le problème ça a
déplacé le problème depuis stalingrad
jusqu'à actuellement donc le jardin
d'eole la nuit mais ça n'a pas changé
vraiment l'acier le problème ça veut
dire que la situation est toujours aussi
pénible pour vous riverains expliquez
nous comment comment ça se passe mais
tant qu'il ya eu une évolution depuis la
dernière fois qu'on vous a parlé
alors depuis lundi soit que vous ai
parlé il ya eu un petit peu plus de
forces de police qui ont été déployés
dans le quartier
nous avons vu effectivement apparaître
des cars de crs déclarent des gendarmes
mobiles qui font un petit peu plus de de
marotte je dirais enfin qu'il se vende
problème un peu plus dans le quartier la
très récemment depuis deux jours on a vu
qu'il y avait effectivement des
mouvements vers le jardin d'eole où il
ya eu enfin tôt dans une installation de
barrières voudront a vu effectivement
que le jardin s'ouvrait à partir de 19h
mais une seulement une petite partie
on n'est pas vraiment sûr que ça
améliore les choses on a vu qu
effectivement il y avait des nouvelles
forces de police donc
ça fait évoluer par contre est-ce que
c'est une bonne évolution est ce que ça
vaut lui dans le bon sens ou pas j'ai un
peu en août
on a l'impression surtout qu'ils ont
déplacé le problème de stalingrad
jusqu'à école parce que staline glas de
il y a du monde et que parfois il peut y
avoir les restos qui vont rouvrir les
cinémas qui vont rouvrir à eole n'ya pas
de cinéma n'y a pas de resto par contre
il ya beaucoup de riverains donc les
riverains peut-être sont un peu sacrifié
au profit de ceux qui ne sont pas
arrivés sains et ont peut-être besoin de
se détendre je sais pas ce qui se passe
exactement mais je suis un peu sceptique
alors il n'est pas question sacrifier
les jardins d'eole a assuré marié de la
mairie pierre lys ya quand vous entendez
le récit de frédéric france elle vous
vous dites quoi on imagine cette colère
des habitants
oui mais une colère d'ailleurs que je
partage parce que j'habite je suis
riverains aussi du quartier j'évite de
l'autre côté en fête des jardins d'eole
donc c'est une problématique que je
connais malheureusement très bien et et
frédéric encel l'a très bien dit on a
déplacé le problème c'est ça la réalité
on a dépassé le problème et ça fait
malheureusement ça fait pas quelques
semaines ça fait pas quelques mois ça
fait trois ans que les pouvoirs publics
déplace le problème il faut quand même
se souvenir que les toxicomanes étaient
présents en masse
il ya quelques années 2018-2019 porte de
la chapelle sur la fameuse colline du
crack et après et après plusieurs mois
de battage médiatique autour de la
colline du crack les les pouvoirs
publics à préfecture à l'époque avait
procédé au démantèlement de la colline
sauf que quand vous démentez la colline
vous éparpiller les toxicomanes dans le
quartier et c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé tant que les toxicomanes ne
sont pas prises en charge dans une danse
dans le cadre d'une prise en charge
sanitaire au long cours il n'ya pas
d'autre choix pour eux que de rester
dans le quartier donc c c'est ainsi que
depuis trois ans il le in their
malheureusement de quartier en quartier
dans le nord-est parisien entre la porte
de la chapelle entre la porte
d'aubervilliers stalingrad
jusqu'à tout récemment et aujourd'hui la
décision qui est prise et non pas de
d'assurer une prise en charge pour
sortir le quartier de cette ornière de
cette impasse de cet enfer mais mais
mais la décision est prise deux
finalement parquet les toxicomanes dans
un espace qui est un jardin pour enfants
moi je veux bien qu'on dise qu'il ya
moins d'habiter y ait moins d'habitants
à l'école qu'à stalingrad
nous avons un jardin pour enfants qu est
immense si un jardin pour enfants savent
bien que nous sommes dans un quartier
résidentiel que nous en nous sommes dans
un quartier où il ya des familles que
nous sommes dans un quartier où il ya a
fortiori des enfants et bien les
pouvoirs publics font le choix font le
choix par cette décision de sacrifier à
la fois cet espace vert qui d'ailleurs
si vous regardez le site de la ville de
paris n'est plus comptabilisé
aujourd'hui n'est plus répertorié
aujourd'hui comme un espace vert de la
ville de paris mais c'est désormais une
salle de shoot à ciel ouvert où on
autorise la consommation de crack et le
deal est évidemment évidemment pour les
riverains de tout le quartier pas
simplement de la rue d'aubervilliers du
jardin des halles pour tous le tous les
quartiers qui jouxte le jardin d'eole
donc une grande partie du nord est
parisien et une quartier stalingrad et
bien c'est un enfer et le pire dans tout
ça c'est que finalement on considère on
considère que le jardin d'eole est
désormais une place libre de deux deals
et de consommation de drogue on a
institutionnalisé le le shoot en pleine
rue et moi je trouve ça un mot minable
et surtout abominable pour les riverains
l'armée propose une opération dans les
prochains jours pour éloigner ces
dealers et consommateurs de crack
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être cette
opération selon vous frédéric france
elle vous êtes optimiste vous avez plein
d'espoir envers ces annonces du ministre
de l'intérieur
klein d'optimisme et d'espoir je suis
pas vraiment certain que ce soit les
mots justes d'optimisme peut-être
effectivement puisque pour le coup il
s'intéresse à nous donc du coup on aura
peut-être effectivement là le avantage
d'avoir quelques cars de crs
supplémentaires etc
par contre ce qui m'inquiète un petit
peu moins c'est le déplacement moi je
veux bien qu'il ait des places mais il
est déplacé ou pour quoi faire
parce que s'ils les déplace uniquement
pour les mettre au milieu d'eux d'autres
riverains sans les soigner tout en les
laissant déambuler au milieu des rues et
de faire n'importe quoi c'est pas une
solution pos c'est pas une solution pour
les riverains non plus si ils ont prévu
par contre de les encadrer de les
prendre et de les mettre dans un lieu
fermé sans public avec je sais pas moi
des moyens fermiers psychosociaux des
choses comme ça et de les soigner tout
en prenant de l'autre côté les dealers
et des
les mettant en prison à la effectivement
ça pourrait être effectivement une très
bonne chose pourquoi je ne sens pas que
ce relative à cette tendance la pierre
lys est romancé plus sur l'identité de
ces toxicomanes je faisais lire tout à
l'heure avec les migrants alors c'est
vrai qu'il ya parmi eux des migrants est
ce que c'est de là que vient toute la
difficulté justement de les encadrer
avec de les gérer on s'est tout
simplement pas où les renvoyer c'est pas
une question de ses peines et ses
peintres une question de savoir où les
renvoyer que de les prendre en charge
médicalement sanitairement c'est surtout
ça la réalité aujourd'hui en fait moi ce
qui me frappe
et ce qui me révolte c'est que
systématiquement les pouvoirs publics
quand on parle de toxicomanie de rue
considère ça comme un problème
sécuritaire uniquement et envoie au
front le ministre de l'intérieur est
donc là on à monsieur darmanin qui nous
explique qu'il va envoyer des forces de
sécurité pour aller quoi déplacer
évacuer les toxicomanes mort a encore
une fois comme le disait frédéric france
elle pour les évacuer ou pour les
déplacés ou aujourd'hui vous discutez
avec les policiers sur le terrain il ya
plusieurs il ya plusieurs centaines de
toxicomanes qui sont en errance dans les
rues du nord-est parisien les policiers
sont sur le terrain constamment mais les
policiers ne peuvent rien faire les
policiers ne peuvent rien faire face à
la diction c'est une maladie face à l'
addiction
les policiers ne peuvent rien faire les
policiers peuvent interpeller
éventuellement les dealers les policiers
peuvent intervenir en cas de risque en
cas de dégradation de l'espace public de
troubles à l'ordre public mais en cas de
maladie à savoir d'une addiction au
crack kill elky l'une des addictions les
plus violentes qui soit et les plus les
plus ravageuse qui soit les policiers ne
peuvent rien faire donc il faut arrêter
de toujours vouloir envoyer de troupes
de toujours vouloir apporter une
solution policière à un problème
sanitaire je le dis je le répète ça fait
trois ans qu'on envoie les flics
pardonnez moi l'expression à chaque fois
sur chaque
ce regroupement de toxicomanes ça fait
trois ans qu'on déplace le problème à
mon il serait peut-être bon de se poser
la question de savoir à quoi bon et se
dira peut-être que le prisme de 2,2 de
la situation qu'on comprend n'est pas le
bon et qu'il faut changer qu'il faut
changer de paradigme et peut-être que au
lieu d'entendre à chaque fois
systématiquement le ministre de
l'intérieur intervenir sur ces sujets là
peut-être que monsieur véran ministre de
la santé pourrait lui aussi monté au
front en première ligne en disant qu'
ils l'ont non pas comme ils vont le
faire comme il s'apprête à le faire
déplacer au parc et des toxicomanes mais
qui vont les soigner il n'ya que en
soignant les toxicomanes qu'on arrivera
à sortir le quartier de l'ornière je le
dis je le répète si s'il n'y a plus de
toxicomanes sur le terrain il n'y a plus
de dealers c'est aussi simple que cela
mais alors là on peut aussi prendre le
problème dans l'autre sens j'allais y
venir justement vous venez d'évoquer des
toxicomanes mais les dealers frédéric
français les ce sera ma dernière
question vous voyez le terrain qu'ils
avaient l'habitude pourquoi ça peut
paraître naïf comme question enfin quand
même pourquoi ça c'est aussi compliqué
de les arrêter tout simplement en
flagrant délit pour commencer alors il
ya plusieurs explications qui peuvent
être donnés je pense
la première c'est que déjà ce sont des
tout-petits dire c'est à dire il n'y a
pas de gros réseaux organisés quasiment
n'importe qui peut avec un petit gramme
de cocaïne et de trois ingrédients
supplémentaires fabriquer du crack
donc n'importe qui dans n'importe quelle
cuisine peut arriver enfin n'importe qui
à condition d'avoir un gramme de cocaïne
évidemment peut arriver à fabriquer du
crack et donc pas par opportunisme
essayer d'aller en vendre y'a pas de
raison donc du coup sacré de tout petits
petits trafics et en plus donc ces
petits trafics peut être remplacée hyper
rapidement il suffit qu'il y en ait deux
queues qui se fasse attraper
et puis il y en a deux autres qui
arrivent directement après le deuxième
difficulté pour pouvoir les attrapé en
flagrant délit c'est qu'ils cachent leur
marchandise dans la bouche et donc du
coup quand il voit deux les policiers
arrivés par exemple donc il ya deux
options soit il la garde dans la bouche
et donc nous parle comme ça un peu
bizarrement je ne vois pas en fait un
policier allait mettre la main dans la
bouche de quelqu'un
s'il ya une caméra en fait il va bien se
passer
et si au pire ils disent bon ben écoute
et voilà on soupçonne que vous avez
quelque chose dans la bouche on va vous
emporter au commissariat le toxicomane
peut tout à fait avaler le produit et le
restituer de façon naturelle je dirais
quelques jours après et donc là du coup
le pas le produit a disparu est donc
très difficile de faire un flagrant
délit ans
merci en tout cas tous les deux pierre
lys ya frédéric française pour ce
problème qui semble malheureusement sans
fin